oh Sam bankman freed is now Sam bankman
Phi Ellen yeah this was apparently news
to bankman Freed he was scheduled to
testify in front of Congress on December
13th and just 24 hours earlier while
playing video games in his Bahamas
Penthouse he told interviewers that he
would have to attend the hearing by Zoom
because he was quite overbooked he also
remarked I don't think I will be
arrested and maybe when he said
overbooked he meant about to be booked
because later that same day authorities
arrested Bank been freed took him into
custody and prepared to extradite him to
the United States where he's been
indicted for wire fraud Securities fraud
Commodities fraud money laundering and
illegal campaign contributions
classic Pisces and now we know that most
of the c-suite at FTX including bankman
Freed's confidants have reached plea
agreements with the government and are
cooperating with the government against
Sam bankman freed and this helps explain
how things moved so quickly and as we
discussed in our last video it looked
like there was going to be a
jurisdictional tussle between Regulators
who would win the right to prosecute
Bank been freed now we know the
Regulators decided that there was enough
criming and torting to go around for
everyone with civil complaints being
filed by the Securities Exchange
Commission the SEC and the Commodities
Futures Trading commission the cftc as
well as criminal charges by the
Department of Justice fortunately for
bankman freed he's used to living with
tons of roommates and wearing the same
clothes every day
[Music]
now before we get into all of the
alleged crimes and there are a lot of
alleged crimes let's do a quick factual
rundown because now we have the benefit
of three detailed proceedings two civil
complaints and one criminal doj
indictment now the SEC and the cftc
filed separate civil complaints
providing additional factual context to
what is alleged to have gone on here as
you probably know bank and freed was the
founder of Alameda research which he
represented as a separate entity from
the FTX entities especially after
Caroline Ellison and sand Trabuco became
co-ceos of Alameda in 2021 however the
SEC and cftc see the banking free did
not hand off Alameda research at all and
that he remained the ultimate decision
maker at Alameda the SEC says that
bankman free directed investment and
operational decisions frequently
communicated with automated employees
and had full access to alameda's records
and databases and the cftc says that
bankman freed operated all of these
entities as a common Enterprise which is
no surprise given the allegations that
we've seen in the news where basically
they were co-mingling all of these funds
so in other words FTX Alameda and many
of their related businesses were all run
by bankman freed and Alameda without any
corporate controls or separation that
bankman free promised the cftc said that
all this was baked into the cake quote
FTX trading Executives also created
other exceptions to fcx's standard
processes to allowed Alameda to have an
unfair Advantage when transacting on the
platform including quicker execution
times and an exemption from the
platform's distinctive Auto Liquidation
risk management process now all of this
started coming out in November you can
check out my earlier video on how this
came to be in December just before
bankman freed was going to testify in
Congress he was arrested in the Bahamas
where he lives the U.S attorney's office
for the southern district of New York
presented evidence to a grand jury the
grand jury indicted him and then the U.S
attorney's Office made provisional
requests for his arrest with the Bahamas
the U.S has an extradition treaty with
the Bahamas and that extradition treaty
will take a while but eventually he will
be transferred to the custody of the
American authorities that means that
bankman Creed faces a three-headed
monster because the SEC and the cftc
cases will have broad Discovery
procedures which will force bankman
freed to turn over documents they'll
have to give a deposition testimony
which could incriminate him in the
criminal case and his lawyers will
probably ask the court to stay in the
civil cases while he defends the
criminal case the judge has the
discretion to decide whether to grant
that motion though don't be surprised if
bankman freed ends up taking the fifth
on a lot of this stuff though in the
Civil proceedings taking the fifth can
be used against you and adverse
inferences can be drawn by your
assertion of the Fifth Amendment though
the SEC has more power than the criminal
court to immediately freeze actions by
the entities that are under the Alameda
FTX banner and The Plea agreements from
sandbankment Freed's compatriots paint a
damning picture former Alameda research
CEO Caroline Ellison and FTX co-founder
Gary Wing have now pleaded guilty to
federal fraud charges and are
cooperating with the Justice
Department's investigation I want to
make two announcements
first I'm announcing that the southern
district of New York has filed charges
against Caroline Ellison the former CEO
of Alameda research and Gary Wong a
co-founder of FTX in connection with
their roles and the frauds that
contributed to fdx's collapse
both Miss Ellison and Mr Wong have pled
guilty to those charges the justice
department made the announcement on
December 22nd the same day the bank been
freed waived extradition to the U.S
bankman freed is now out of jail and
back in his mom's basement as a result
the federal court set bail at 250
million dollars and bankman freed was
bonded out now a bail bond is usually
about 10 percent of the total bail
amount so we probably had to come up
with around 25 million dollars in assets
the court record shows that his parents
will need to post Equity interest in
their home by January 12 2023 and this
comes just weeks after bankman free told
George Stephanopoulos that he only had
about a hundred thousand dollars left in
his bank account now the bail
disposition said the two non-parent
Charities would also sign bonds for
lesser amounts the terms of the release
require bankman free to surrender his
passport and he'll be confined to
detention at his parents home in Palo
Alto California where he will have to
wear an ankle monitor bankman Freed's
parents co-signed the bond and bankman
freed is barred from starting a business
or operating new lines of credit more
than one thousand dollars less approved
by the government or the court the court
records show that he'll need to undergo
a mental health valuation and may
request to leave the house for exercise
now Caroline Ellison's unsigned plea
agreement says that she admitted to
seven counts including committing wire
fraud on FTX customers and lenders of
Alameda research conspiracy to commit
Commodities fraud and securities fraud
and conspiracy to commit money
laundering now the maximum sentence of
incarceration on those counts is 110
years but she's not going to face
anything like that especially because
she's cooperating but Ellison must
continue to cooperate or else she could
be charged with other crimes Ellison
also agreed to the forfeiture charge and
the government says that it cannot agree
not to prosecutor for tax fraud if those
charges are appropriate by pleading
guilty Ellison is not guaranteed a
lighter sentence but typically
defendants who cooperate completely do
get a lighter sentence and The Plea
agreements also require her to make
restitution Ellison was released on bail
but cannot leave the country Wang
pleaded guilty to four counts of wire
fraud and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud Commodities fraud and securities
fraud the maximum sentence for those
crimes is about 50 years in prison Wang
also agreed to restitution to his
victims and agreed to the forfeiture now
the same cooperation terms applying to
Wang but he was also released on fail
with the condition that he not leave the
country both plea agreements included
sections that are redacted so as not to
tip off bankman freed and other targets
about specific information that Ellison
and Wang shared with investigators and
in separate actions the SEC charged Wang
and Ellison with Securities fraud and
the cftc also filed fraud charges
against Ellison Wang the cftc's amended
complaint against bankman freed adds
charges against Ellison and weighing for
fraud and material representations in
connection with the sale of digital
asset Commodities in interstate commerce
and the cftc hit Wang for creating the
code features in the FTX trading
platform that allowed Alameda to have an
unlimited credit line on FTX without
being detected and the cftc complaint
offers more details about what happened
in November when crypto declined in FTX
could not keep up with customer
withdrawals publicly Bank been freed
claimed that there was just a liquidity
problem while privately quote bankman
freed Ellison and other key personnel at
FTX and Alameda acknowledged internally
that this shortfall was not merely a
matter of having sufficient liquid
assets on hand to cover customer
withdrawals in the short term rather FTX
customer assets were irrevocably lost
because Alameda had appropriated them
the cftc says the bankman Freed's
Infamous tweet threads of November 6th
and 7th the ones where he apologized for
being a screw-up and accused binance of
trying to sabotage FTX were workshopped
ahead of time with Ellison Wang and
other advisers the cftc says quote
several individuals expressed concerns
that bankman Freed's tweet was
inaccurate and or misleading and on
November 9th after binance announced
that it would acquire FTX in its
entirety Ellison held an all hands
meeting with employees of elevated
research during the meeting she provided
detailed information about the
years-long fraud quote Ellison stated
that starting last year Alameda was
borrowing a bunch of money by open term
loans and used those assets to make very
illiquid Investments Ellison further
explained that following the widespread
decline of digital asset prices most of
alameda's loans had been recalled and in
order to meet those recalls Alameda
borrowed a bunch of funds from FTX which
in turn led to FTX having a shortfall in
user funds Ellison informed alanada
staff at FTX had always allowed Alameda
to borrow customer assets and did not
require collateral for those loans she
also explained that Alameda could access
user assets without requiring ftx's
approval as the structure allowed
alimeda to go negative in coins in
response to employee question Ellison
also acknowledged that her November 6
tweet to the binance CEO offering to buy
his ftt Holdings at 22 per token was
kind of a misleading thing to tweet and
express remorse shortly after this
meeting most of alameda's Staff resigned
so basically Caroline Ellison sort of
admitted to you know like borrowing a
bunch of money from FTX being allowed to
have like a negative balance and that
FTX now made it just kept moving stuff
around until the bottom dropped out of
the market and then you know what do you
no there's nothing left to borrow and
the customers couldn't withdraw their
money
classic Pisces one day later FTX and 133
related entities file for bankruptcy I
declare
bankruptcy
it was all you know very cool very
Progressive very edgy until you know it
wasn't Ellison and Wang do not contest
their liability to these cftc's claims
and their testimony makes it very hard
for bankman free to claim that he didn't
know what he was doing in ah Shucks he
was just a big old mistake Wayne Ellison
also agreed to the entry of consent
orders of judgment as to their liability
for engaging in massive fraud the SEC
complaint against Wang Nelson gives us
more clues about how they were
cooperating against bankman freed with
respect to the Fiat ftx.com account the
SEC said that some of the bank accounts
were not in alameda's name but rather
than the name of North Dimension Inc in
Alameda subsidiary North dimension's
website does not disclose any connection
to Alameda but apparently Ellison knew
that bankman freed had directed FTX to
have customers send funds to North
dimension in an effort to hide the fact
that the funds were being sent to an
account controlled by Alameda apparently
Alameda didn't segregate those customer
funds and the north Dimension account is
actually the multi-billion dollar debt
referred to as the Fiat at ftx.com
account
the Fiat at FTX count uh was then listed
as a loan on the quarterly balance
sheets and Ellison allegedly at bankman
Freed's Direction combined this
liability with loans Alameda had
received from third party lenders to
obscure alameda's intertwined Financial
relationship with FTX now this
information if true is fairly damning
evidence of the defendant's intent to
mislead and conceal information from
investors lenders and customers the the
complaint says in 2022 FTX started
trying to separate alameda's debt in the
Fiat ftx.com account from the portion
attributable to FTX and when alameda's
portion was moved to a different account
it triggered a process that added
interest to alameda's debt quote bankman
free directed that the animated
liability be moved to an account that
would not be charged with interest this
account was associated with an
individual that had no apparent
connection to Alameda as a result this
change had the effect of further
concealing alameda's liability in ftx's
internal systems and when crypto started
crashing in May causing alameda's
lenders to come calling bankman free
told Ellison to hide the unlimited line
of credit on the balance sheet so so
that the lenders didn't know about it
and Ellison admitted to making
statements that she knew were untrue for
example in a Bloomberg article from
September 2022 bankman freed claimed
that Alameda is a wholly separate entity
than FTX and in the same article Ellison
is quoted as stating about Alameda quote
where at arm's length we don't get any
different treatment from other market
makers and as for the technical issues
Wang designed the so-called risk engine
that benkmanfree touted to investors the
SEC complaint notes that bankman freed
touted this risk protocol when he
testified to Congress quote there's a
complete transparency about the
positions that are held there's a robust
consistent risk framework applied of
course one of the biggest problems is
the risk engine didn't apply to ftx's
biggest customer Alameda research Wang
knew this because he was the person who
created the code exempting Alameda
research from the rules and that Ellison
was aware of and took advantage of this
special undisclosed benefit of course
this is just scratching the surface
there's additional juicy details about
Alameda propping up the price of ftt FTX
using Bots to manipulate the entire
market and then the employees and
Founders issuing giant loans to each
other at the company's expense now the
SEC complaint alleges the bankman freed
violated two parts of the Securities
Exchange Act of 1933 breach of section
17A and 10B both of these sections
prohibit making false representations to
investors as opposed to customers who
would be the exchange's users now the
Crux of the sec's charges are the
bankman freed transferred billions of
dollars of FTX money to elevated
research while misleading ftx's
investors about ftx's financial
condition and risk management at the end
of the day
look there's a question of what happened
and why Alameda used this money to cover
loans and make additional Venture
Investments and personal loans to bank
and freed and other FTX Investments
even in November 2022 faced with
billions of dollars in customer
withdrawal demands that FTX could not
fulfill bankman freed misled investors
about a multi-billion dollar hole now
the SEC allege the bankman freed
committed fraud in the offer or sale of
Securities in violation of section 17A
the section makes it legal to mislead
investors specifically it says it's
unlawful to employ any device scheme or
artifice to defraud obtain money or
property by using material misstatements
or missions or to engage in any
transaction practice or course of
business which operates or would operate
as a fraud or deceit upon the purchaser
now the SEC typically relies more on
rule 10 B5 for its enforcement actions
but in recent years has stepped at
prosecutions under 17A in part because
of the regulations weaker sienta
requirements now siento is another word
for the mental intent the knowledge of
wrongdoing and when the SEC brings a
civil case as it did here a violation of
section 17A can be established if the
defendant acted negligently in contrast
to civil violation of rule 10 B5
requires that the defendant must have
acted at least recklessly which is a
higher mental state than just negligence
the SEC says that bank and freed allowed
Alameda to have a negative balance on
its account without any collateral
requirements and gave Alameda unlimited
access to credit no other account had
these Privileges and they were
accomplished by writing Alameda specific
bypasses in the FTX code base in August
2019. alameda's collateral was also
allowed to fall below the requisite
margin levels without triggering the
automatic liquidation of its account and
while bankman freed pulled strings to
give Alameda these special privileges he
did not disclose any of them to FTX
investors though news reports also
suggest that investors did not do proper
due diligence in FTX but perhaps that
was partly because bankman free did not
give the investors much information to
work with telling them to look at the
terms of service and pointing to a
document called ftx's key principles for
ensuring investor protections on digital
asset Platforms in which FDX claimed
that it quote segregates customer assets
from its own assets across our platforms
now the SEC says FTX provided this
document to potential investors quote
including a US investor who invested 35
million dollars in ftx's series B 5
fundraising round in July 2021 but these
statements were false as FTX did not
segregate customer assets from its own
assets and as events would later
demonstrate did not maintain liquidity
to allow customer withdrawals on demand
now FTX did provide audited financials
but those statements don't include
information about alameda's undocumented
line of credit from FTX or the other
information about its special deals with
Alameda bankman freed told investors
that Alameda did not get any special
treatment and that he told his
Executives to emphasize that FTX and
Alameda were two separate entities the
SEC says that all of that was materially
misleading and that seems kind of like a
slam dunk case now the SEC also alleges
the bankman freed violated section 10 B5
the more traditional fraud Provisions
that are used in a situation like this
the SEC alleges that bank and freed used
Creative Accounting and little
documentation to hide his personal loans
according to the complaint between March
2020 and September 2022 benkman freed
executed promissory notes for loans from
Alameda totaling more than
1.338 billion dollars including two
instances in which bankman freed was
both the borrower in his individual
capacity and and the lender in his
capacity as CEO of Alameda bankman free
used these loans to make political
contributions and buy real estate for
himself his parents and other FTX
Executives and besides all of this the
SEC alleges that quote the
record-keeping regarding the purchase
and ownership of real estate was poorly
organized and documented neither the
fact of the loans and the purchases nor
the poor documentation of significant
company liabilities and expenditures was
disclosed to investors so you do know
and you did know that FDX deposits were
being funneled to Alameda so I was
vaguely aware that that was how some
virus were being sent in the first place
now I'm sensing a theme here now the SEC
also cites a September 2022 meeting for
U.S investors in which FTX claimed quote
outside of blockfi we didn't increase
our exposure to crypto that statement
was quote false and misleading bankman
freed knew that as a result ftx's
exposure to crypto including its own ftt
token increased substantially as Alameda
increases borrowing backed by ftt as
collateral now the SEC lawsuit is a
civil enforcement action which means
that it isn't charging bank then free
criminally that's what the doj is doing
but the complaint seeks disgorgement I.E
paying back of all the ill-gotten gains
civil penalties a ban on bankman freed
acting as an officer or director of a
company and to prohibit him from
participating in the issuance purchase
offer or sale of any Securities in the
future now that takes us to the cftc
complaint now I told you before that the
cftc believed that it had the authority
to regulate crypto as a commodity and
his complaint against bankman freed and
FTX makes no bones about it quote
certain and digital assets are
Commodities including Bitcoin ether
tether and others as defined under the
commodity exchange act thus the agency
filed a complaint naming bankman freed
FTX trading limited and elevated
Research LLC as defendants much of the
cftc's complaint reiterates facts let
out concurrently in the sec's complaint
including all the stuff about the
special treatment evaluated research
that it got from FTX and the fact that
elementa research served as a limitless
slush fund for bankman freed and other
FTX Executives in fact the cftc says
that these built-in advantages for
element a quote directly contradicted
public statements made by and on behalf
of defendants this allowed Alameda to
use FTX assets whenever it needed to pay
off its own lenders the cftc says that
FTX also made a giant no interest loan
to Alameda which it concealed with the
now Infamous line item on the balance
sheet called Fiat at quote during the
relevant period this account held a
balance of as much as 8 billion dollars
in customer funds now that wasn't the
only time the bank been freed used a
weird trick your accountant doesn't want
you to know about to hide an enormous
live ability uh quote at least in part
to remediate the risk that alameda's
large liability would be discovered a
begman Freed's discretion FTX Executives
reallocated alameda's approximately one
billion dollars in liabilities to a
customer account on ftx's system that
bankman freed would later refer to as
our Korean friends account and or the
weird Korean account this was
technically a sub account of Alameda but
unlike other Alameda sub-accounts on FTX
it was not opened under a at Alameda
research.com identifier and was not
otherwise readily identifiable as being
an alimeda Associated account this in
plain terms uh seems like fraud in the
cftc charge bank and freed with
violating section 6C of the Commodities
exchange act which is basically pattern
after rule 10B of the Securities and
Exchange act the law is a broad sort of
catch-all provision that prohibits fraud
in all of its forms and the law
prohibits manipulative and deceptive
devices and contrivances in connection
with any swap or contract to basically
anything in relation to the sale of a
commodity now the newest amendments the
law were added in 2010 by the Dodd-Frank
Act which make it easier for the cftc to
charge fraud because the government no
longer has to prove that a defendant
specifically intended to create a price
trend that was manipulative now the cfdc
can charge anyone who uses manipulative
or deceptive devices is intentionally
reckless in conduct that's intended to
create or did create an artificial price
now that takes us to the criminal
indictment from the Department of
Justice the U.S attorney's office for
the southern district of New York which
handles a lot of financial crimes
because New York City is within the
southern district of New York and they
obtained an indictment against bankman
freed for conspiracy to commit wire
fraud wire fraud conspiracy to commit
Commodities fraud conspiracy to commit
Securities fraud conspiracy to commit
money laundering and conspiracy to
defraud the Federal Election Commission
and commit campaign Finance violations
now we kicked off our first video about
bankman freed by discussing the
possibility of wire fraud and what do
you know it was wire fraud wire fraud
specifically involves the use of
telecommunications or online
Communications including emails social
media text messages or even good
old-fashioned fax machines the unsealed
indictment says that starting in 2019
and continuing until November of 2022
bankman freed committed wire fraud now
this might not have come as a complete
shock to bankman free because according
to the Australian website financial
review bankman freed and his FTX and
alimated Associates had a secret chat
group called cryptically wire fraud the
group exchanged secret messages on
Signal about the potential for U.S wire
fraud charges for their role in the
implosion of FTX and elevated research
in response to the allegation bankman
freed tweeted if this is true then I
wasn't a member of that inner circle I'm
quite sure it's just false I have never
heard of such a group though on the
other hand maybe he just wanted to save
the Department of Justice a whole bunch
of money in making it super easy to
prosecute him and everyone that he
worked with and as I mentioned the
government also criminally charged
bankman freed with various species of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud
Securities fraud Commodities fraud money
laundering and campaign Finance
violations and regarding that last
charge prosecutors said the bankman
freed Miss appropriated tens of millions
of dollars of customer funds to make
illegal donations to both Democratic and
Republican candidates so the question is
is if bankman freed is convicted how
long is he going to jail well the cftc
and the SEC filed civil complaints
seeking monetary damages and injunctive
relief to prevent bankman freed from
being near a corporation or a company
ever again now the fines could be
enormous in this case but it'll probably
take a long time to resolve with
potentially years of Discovery and a
string of bankruptcies to sort things
through the criminal case filed by the
Department of Justice will go much
faster now begman freed was indicted for
a number of different Federal felonies
some of which meld into each other but
some are separate counts and unlike the
cftc and the SEC complaints that the doj
convicts sambang big freed could be
looking at a long sentence the amount of
time he gets depends on two things the
offenses of conviction and the federal
sentencing guidelines the sentencing
guidelines provide 43 levels of offense
seriousness that more serious the crime
the higher the offense level and each
type of crime is assigned a base offense
level which is the starting point for
determining the seriousness of the
particular offense now bang bang freed
is not a prior offender which would
normally reduce the sentence but the
nature of his crimes is serious and
there are at least three different
groups of victims here lenders customers
and the United States government now
wire fraud carries a maximum prison
sentence of up to 20 years and if the
wire fraud involves over 550 million
dollars which is possible if not likely
here then bankman free could get a
maximum sentence even without a prior
criminal history Securities fraud
carries a maximum sentence of up to 25
years in prison and a fine that is based
on the amount of money that was
fraudulently obtained which here was a
lot and a conviction for money
laundering could result in a sentence of
up to 20 years and a big fine so if we
look at it conservatively assuming the
government proves some but not all the
charges bankman freed could get a census
of 10 to 15 years there's still a lot of
things that we don't know since cases
still in its very early stages and it
could be a lot more than that now maybe
the strangest Story related to spf's
arrest is that his family reportedly
called the prison to request vegan meals
now that's not going to happen but he
could get a delicious vegan meal from
today's sponsor factor or a keto meal or
a high protein meal or a calorie smart
meal because Factor makes meeting your
nutrition goals easier than ever by
delivering fresh never Frozen in
dietitian approved meals right to your
doorstep unless you're sandbankment free
and the meals are completely ready to
eat their team of gourmet chefs creates
each meal using only ingredients with
Integrity to help you feel your best all
day long Factor supports wholesome
eating Made Simple their menus are
updated weekly it includes over 27 meals
and 33 add-ons you can choose your
favorite meals or like Factor craft your
order based on your taste preferences
and meal history Factor takes the
guesswork out of grocery shopping and
meal prep saving you time and energy for
other things factors no hassle prepared
foods make sure that you always have
something nutritious on hand when you
don't have time to think about making a
meal and sometimes I just want a
delicious healthy meal without having to
cook in fact there's meals arrived
pre-packaged and ready eat in just two
minutes meal plans range from 4 to 18
meals per week so I can always scale up
my meals if I need the extra energy for
a long day of lawyering and factors now
owned by hellofresh so there's a wider
array of meal plans to choose from
there's something for everyone whether
you want to cook it yourself or have a
meal ready to go so give Factor Try by
going to go.factor75.com Legal eagle60
and use the code legal eagle60 to get 60
off your first Factor boxes or just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description and use
the code legal eagle60 to get 60 off
across six boxes after that click on
this box over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court